hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well is now going to
turn to focus his attention on what we
have says his time come to call the
intellectual virtues
these are dispositions or in Greek
hexxus those habits then are established
within the intellectual or rational part
of the human soul as opposed to the
irrational part which is where we see
the moral virtues established it's
important to note of course that reason
which which is happening up in this this
area on the soul we might say is very
much involved in the moral virtues but
they have to do with the the part of the
soul that can listen to reason
but isn't itself reasonable we'll talk
about that in just a moment so you
notice that we've got five things
written here intellect also translated
as intelligence mind sometimes
wisdom scientific knowledge art skill
and prudence these are the five
intellectual virtues these are
dispositions that can be gradually as
- within a person's soul or if you don't
like the the theological implications of
soul which actually ourselves doesn't do
yeah if that word bothers you think
personality or character or personhood
now when we're talking about parts of
the soul which is where he really begins
it's important to keep in mind something
that he said in nikka McCann ethics book
one where some of this information is
actually coming from and also in the day
anima or on the soul where he's
specifically talking about the soul
which is that when we're talking about
parts these are not things like solid
parts of the machine that cannot occupy
the same space that don't interpenetrate
in any way they're not separable they're
not you know different things totally
apart from each other in some box that
we call the soul rather they are
characteristic functions you might say
of that same soul and you know Aristotle
says at one point you could think of
them as being related like the convex is
to the concave they're not really
radically distinct from each other
although we can't distinguish them from
each other and there are interactions
that they they are carrying out so we're
going to work our way on up to the parts
that we're really interested in mainly
just so we can at the very beginning get
rid of the things that we're not
particularly interested if you notice
Aristotle divides assault into a
rational part and an irrational part the
irrational part is what we share in
common with animals and even other
living things like plants or you know if
Aristotle did about bacteria he would
probably place them in there
the lowest part of the soul big part of
the soul probably has a whole bunch of
different you know sub functions it is
what he calls the practical syndrich and
we typically translate this as
vegetative in part because it's
something that plants themselves do
but also when we talk about a person
being in a vegetative state really
that's all that's going on with them the
vegetative part of the soul handles
things like digestion for example you
know it's fortunate that you don't
actually have to deliberate about
digestion although you may deliberate
about what you want to put it right or
anything to take supplements or anything
like that but you don't have to think
about the processes themselves because
if you did when you get nothing done all
day long with you so a lot of those
things just really handle themselves on
their way
aerosol doesn't tell us much about this
certainly not in terms of ethics or
intellectual life that would higher than
that is the part that we share in common
with animals this is the erecting comb
erectus is the most wide-ranging term
that Aristotle uses for all forms of
activity designer emotion the things
that we feel mood if you like as well
you know this part like I put here is
effective and desirous it is amenable to
reason in human beings though not not in
animals other animals because we're
animals as well but in other animals
it's not according to Aristotle amenable
to reason but it's not by itself going
to automatically take its marching
orders from reeds and it does what it
does and this is the realm where the
moral virtues the excellences of
character which have to do with actions
and emotions as well as a few other
things like how we value goods that's
we're that part of the those are lodged
you might say in that part of the slope
they certainly brought upon the rational
part of the soul in order to be virtues
as Aristotle in sales we discussed in
other videos
however they are they are in that part
of the soul and they're part of that
they're there they're a portion of that
part of the souls activities when we
turn to the rational part you notice
we've got two terms here that Aristotle
uses to say let's call them this and
that there's a higher part of the
rational soul and a lower part of the
rational soul and the lower part of the
rational soul is particularly connected
with the effective or desirous or ratty
cond part of the irrational saw the
highest party calls the piston Monique
cone this is coming from the Greek word
for knowledge a piston a and as he says
this is the part that engages in
contemplates contemplation of theoria
or theory things whose first principles
don't change now that doesn't mean that
the things that it's thinking about
we're observing or reasoning about or
any of those sorts of activities don't
themselves change but their first
principles don't change and then the
other part of the soul the logistic own
you know we can call this a a reasoning
it's translated in some cases as
calculative right Aristotle also says we
can call this a deliberative faculty a
faculty that engages in deliberation
which that affects what goes on in here
it contemplates things whose first
principles do in fact change so not only
do the things themselves change but what
would happen as first principles might
change from situation to situation and
what we're going to see is that there's
a very strong connection between what we
can call truth in in thought and truth
in action or truth in desire between the
you know speculative or pure reason
right and practical reason Aristotle is
going to draw these out in different
ways but it's
important to note there is a distinction
here in Aristotle's making that
distinction in particularly in terms of
the activities and the objects of these
parts of the soul why does he do that
well he goes out and he says here we go
on the assumption that knowledge is
based on a likeness or affinity of some
sort between subject and object the
parts of the soul adapted to the
cognition of objects that are different
kinds must themselves differ in kind so
the parts of the soul they have are
engaged with knowing or reasoning or
deliberating or thinking in any sort of
way to the part of what makes us
distinctively human are going to be
conditioned by then your objects are
going to be sort of tailored to them so
here's where we make the move now from
these parts of the soul to the
intellectual virtues and let's draw a
dividing line right here as well let's
actually start with the lowest part you
notice that we've got two entries in
there one is art of our skill technique
which we're going to do another video
specifically about going in further
depth about that
and then there's prudence prudence our
practical wisdom phronesis
something that in Plato sometimes is
used synonymously with wisdom Sophia but
in Aristotle has a distinct meaning
notice too that prudence has some sort
of connection to the moral virtues but
is not itself one of the moral virtues
as it is for some other philosophers
it's not for Aristotle this there is
instead of a distinction there so our
skill is productive it allows us to make
things to create things to make things
happen
in certain ways to produce things where
they weren't before
prudence has to do not with places or
production but with action as such and
hillarie means to to proper ads so it's
going to govern conduct both of these
are practical in the broad sense but
this is practical and this is productive
intellect sometimes translated as
intelligence sometimes translated as as
mine is the Greek term noose and
sometimes also da Noya as well and
intellect it is going to in some ways
straddle this this field intellect
consists in the grasp of these first
principles so first principles are our
case starting points that we begin from
when we're thinking about things when
we're reasoning when we're inferring
right when we're deliberating as well
intellect is what supplies us with those
so intellect will play a major role here
in the theoretical part but it also will
play a role for prudence as well wisdom
Sophia this is actually Aristotle
considers to be the highest of the
intellectual virtues the in some
respects the the greatest or the best
it's part of what philosophers are after
and he says some philosophers actually
did get us presumably you could have
concluded self among them and this is
primarily oriented towards the
theoretical we're going to see in a bit
that wisdom and scientific knowledge
that we turn to the video on that are
closely connected as is intellect
now scientific knowledge this is the
term that we're using here to translate
the Greek catch-all a piston a the word
that we get epistemology from this does
mean knowledge and when we talk about a
particular branch of knowledge we're
talking about one of the sciences so
scientific knowledge about something
means understanding what that thing
is it's not just a productive knowledge
aerosol is making a strong distinction
between technique and the Piston may
hear something that by the way again
Plato did not particularly observe he
kept shifted back and forth between
these eras I will consider scientific
knowledge to be something that is
concerned with this part of the
intellect so it's concerned with the
things that that don't change or the
whose principles don't change yeah you
know these down here are concerned with
the much more malleable practical sphere
as well so each one of these can be
parsed out a little bit further in eros
level does that we'll do that in other
videos and notice that was some of these
for example Tecna or other skill or
scientific knowledge we can also talk
about types of scientific knowledge you
know for example knowledge of physics or
knowledge of biology knowledge of other
things as well
different arts or skills making boots is
not the same thing as making wobbuff
there there isn't need a tech native
that as some people thought there was or
making victory through military strategy
alone notice that Aristotle will
consider military science and a piston
may have had certain points so this
gives you a broad overview of how these
five intellectual virtues that Aristotle
is particularly interested them are
connected up with the human soul and its
various parts particularly in the
rational part